الى تركيا حيث يجتمع تكتل المعارضه بعد
انسحاب حزب الجيد ثاني اكبر احزاب
المعارضه من التكتل لاثراء خلاف على مرشح
الرئاسه في الانتخابات العامه في مايو
زعيمه الحزب المنسحب ميرال
صرحت ان الاحزاب الخمسه المعارضه اقترحت
كمال
زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري مرشحا للرئاسه
وهو ما لم يوافق عليه حزبه
وعلى وقع هذه الاجتماعات هناك حرب سياسيه
احتدمت قبل عشره اسابيع من موعد
الانتخابات العامه في تركيا المقرره في
مايو القادم شقاق على الطاوله السداسيه
طبعا هي ما يطلق عليه تكتل احزاب المعارضه
التركيه شقاق ازاح الحزب الجيد من التكتل
بعدما اعلنت رئيسيته ميرال الشكنار عن
ضغوط تمارس عليها من قبل الاحزاب الخمسه
الاخرى الاحزاب الخمسه اتفقت على تسميه
كمال اجلو رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري مرشحا
لرئاسه الجمهوريه اسم رفضته كنار معتبره
انه اضعف من اي واجهه الرئيس الحالي
اردوغان اشكنار دعت كلا من اكرم امام
اوغلو ومنصور يواش عضوه حزب الشعب
الجمهوري للترشح ليبقى يا امام خيارين اما
الاستقاله او الاتهام بالخيانه او البقاء
تحت مظله الحزب ورئيسه المرشح للمنصب لا
يصعب على الطاوله السداسيه ان تجد بديل
للحزب المنسحب فحزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه
الكردي هو ايضا خيار اساسي امام كمال
اوغلول لاكتمال نصاب تكتل المعارضه الا ان
الحزب يرفض الصبغه القوميه التي تطغى على
الطاوله المعارضه فوضى سياسيه بين اطراف
المعارضه تزامت مع انشغال حكومه اردوغان
باعاده الاعمار بعد كارثه الزلزال لتبقى
الحكومه والمعارضه ايضا مصره على اجراء
الانتخابات في موعدها المحدد يبدو ان
اردوغان اكبر المستفيدين من انقسام
المعارضه اخيرا
المزيد معنا من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه
زيدان زنكلو اهلا بك زيدان اخر المعلومات
لديك حول هذا النقاش فيما يتعلق بالمعارضه
نعم ميسون قبل قليل وصل كمالك الجدار
اوغلو رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري وزعيم
المعضله التركيه الى مقر حزب السعاده
استعدادا لبدء الاجتماع الخماسي
لا نتحدث اليوم عن طاوله سداسيه ولكن
اجتماع خماسي بغياب ميرال ثاني اكبر حزب
معارض في تركيا التي وجهت يوم امس
انتقادات لاذعه لافراد او قاده احزاب
الطاوله السداسيه باختيارهم كمالك الجدار
اوغلو يوم امس كان يوما ساخنا في كل
الاحزاب المعارضه كل الاحزاب تقريبا عقدت
اجتماعات طارئه ما بين قاده الاحزاب
وقيادات الحزب الرئيسيه للتباحث في هذا
المستجد الطارئ
ولا نقول غير المتوقع لكن الخلاف انتقل من
من خلف الابواب المغلقه الى العالم بشكل
كبير نعم
هذا ما
حتى الان هذا السؤال وجهها الى نائب ميرال
في مقابله تلفزيونيه قال ان الباب مفتوح
لكن كلمه الباب مفتوح وضعها وضع امامها
عده شروط وهو اختيار المرشح بالاجماع وهذا
يعني ان اختيارات ميرال اكشنر تحديدا
خيارات ميرال اكشن لمنصب الرئيس اما امام
اوغلو او يواش يجب ان تطبق وبالتالي هذا
الموضوع بشكل عام مرفوض من قبل كمالك
الجدار اوغلو زعيم المعارضه وحتى ايضا من
امام اوغلو ويواش اللذان يوم امس صرحا
بشكل علني انهما يدعمان رئيس الحزب كمالك
الجدار اوغلو وقال انهما سيلتقيان هذا
اليوم بميرال اكشنر في محاوله لاقناعها
بالعوده عن هذا الموقف لكن حتى الان
المؤشرات تقول ان عمليه الاقناع غير ممكنه
لاسيما ان اكشنر تقول ان فرص سواء كان
امام اوبلو او يواش اقوى في منافسه الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان وربما الفوز في
الانتخابات لكن فرص كمالك الجدار اوغلو
غير مضمونه ابدا لذلك لن تغامر بقبول
هذه التصريحات
والقراءه مبنيه على ماذا ما هي المعطيات
التي بنت عليها هذه النسب او ان الشارع
يميل الى هذا دون ذاك
نعم هي استطلاعات اساسا كانت منشوره او
نشرتها عده مراكز دراسات قبل حادثه
الزلزال المدمر وايضا لحزب الخير ولكل
الاحزاب هناك
مراكز ودراسات تحاول جس النبض في الشارع
خصوصا في فتره ما بعد الزلزال
ركزت ميرال اكشنر على المناطق المنكوبه
واستطلعت يعني بهذا ما قالته خلال
الاجتماع وما دار وراء الكواليس ان كل
البيانات القادمه من الارض والشارع سواء
في المناطق المنكوبه او غير المنكوبه تفضل
ترشيح اما يا واش او امام اوغلو وبالتالي
هي
والكلام لميرا لن تغامر بفرصه تاريخيه
يمكن من خلالها الفوز على الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بترشيح كمالك الجدار اوغلو حديثها
من مناطق منكوبه وخاصه موضوع الزلزال
موضوع شائك هناك من يتهم الحكومه بالتقصير
وهناك من يقول انه لا التعاطي معه في ظل
حجم الازمه طبيعي جدا كيف اثر على اردوغان
وكيف يمكن ان يؤثر عليه فيما يتعلق
بالانتخابات
لا شك ان الحكومه كان هناك جانب كبير
موضوع التقصير في الاستجابه للكارثه
الكبيره نعم هناك كان كارثه كبيره ضربت 11
ولايه لكن هناك تقصير وعدم استجابه كافيه
من الحكومه خصوصا في الساعات والايام
الاولى هذا الموضوع لا يمكن اخفاء هذا
الموضوع ونحن كنا هناك وكنا نتابع كل
التفاصيل كان هناك تقصير وكان هناك خلل في
عده نواحي في التعاطي مع الزلزال لكن يعني
دائما الرياح الرياح السياسه التركيه تسير
وفق ما يشتهيه رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس
الحالي الكل كان يتوقع انه سيتاثر بشكل
سلبي من موضوع الزلزال لكن جاء هذا الخلاف
بين احزاب المعارضه ليعطي فرصه اضافيه
للرئيس اردوغان وكما قال هو قبل قليل
اليوم كان له تصريح في التعليق على هذا
الموضوع عندما قال قلنا سابقا ان هذا
مشروع الطاوله السداسيه سيفشل والان
تشاهدون ما يحصل يعني هذا الرئيس التركي
يوجه رساله الى الشارع التركي انه لا حتى
الان غير قادرين على الاتفاق على مرشح
مشترك وعقد الطاوله بدا بالانفراط وهذا
ايضا يعطي ميزه للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في الانتخابات القادمه